oh boy friends WWDC 2023 is here it has
happened the keynote is over and we got
a bunch of new things obviously Vision
Pro was the stage stealer it was the
highlight of the show but there's so
much more that happened that I feel like
sometimes people aren't going to talk
about because they're just going to want
to talk about Vision Pro which is
obviously kind of like all I want to
talk about as well so I made a full
video going more in depth on some of the
features and my hands-on experience with
it so what else happened at WWDC so they
started off they announced a new 15-inch
MacBook Air which is really exciting I'm
such a huge fan of the MacBook Air and
of course this has the new M2 Chip it's
11.5 millimeters thin it's the thinnest
15 inch laptop and it's three pounds
it's got mag safe and two Thunderbolt
ports there's four colors we've got the
liquid Retina Display with five
millimeter borders it's got 500 nits of
brightness 1 billion colors 1080p camera
and a three mic array it's also got six
speakers and spatial audio and this has
the M2 Chip with eight core c pu in a 10
core GPU it's 12 times faster than the
fastest Intel based Mac with 18 hours of
battery life much like all of the other
MacBook airs it is silent and it has no
fans it really is taking advantage of
that M2 Chip these are priced at 12.99
and they are available to order now the
Mac Studio is such a beautiful little
computer and I'm so glad that they're
still keeping this in the lineup this
also got an update today the Mac Studio
now has an M2 Mac chip and it's 25
faster than an M1 rendering up to 50
percent faster than M1 and it's
introducing a new M2 Ultra chip this
combines two M2 Max chips that's that's
a lot of chips 24 core CPU 76 core GPU
and it supports up to 192 gigs of memory
I almost hit the floor on that one like
that's just
like you can do 22 streams of 8K yeah 22
and you better believe we'll be trying
that out it's also got higher band with
HDMI up to 8K resolution and it supports
up to six Pro display xdrs like that's
how much money is that what's six times
what's that math 36
000 for this place holy moly I need
another line of credit also a fan
favorite the new Mac Pro is now getting
the M2 treatment and I could not be more
excited I am just I still love this
design and I remember being at WWDC when
they first announced the Mac Pro might
have been one of the best days of my
life and now today might be the best day
of my life so there's that every Mac Pro
now comes with an M2 Ultra chip 24 core
CPU 76 core GPU and of course will
support up to 192 gigs of memory now it
has an afterburner card but it's
actually the equivalent of seven
afterburner cards all in one thanks to
the new M2 Chip this is something that I
was most excited about eight freaking
Thunderbolt ports that is so beautiful
like that is just music to my ears now
the Mac Pro is definitely made for
customization especially doing higher
end music production video production
you need that power and those ports to
be able to support all of those external
devices this now has six Gen 4 PCI slots
the new Mac Pro is starting at six
thousand nine hundred and ninety nine
dollars which when you actually spec all
of this out and you see what is all
there that's not bad at all now iOS 17
is also something that they talked about
they haven't really updated the phone
app in a very long time so this was kind
of cool they have these new personalized
posters you can customize how you look
when you call someone with photos memoji
and text and it's also connected to your
contact card so when you share your
contact that'll be shared with the
person that you're sharing with live
voicemail is actually really awesome and
I'm hyped about this because I don't
like listening to voicemail but you can
actually see the live transcriptions
showing up as someone is leaving a
message so like if they're saying saying
something important you can pick it up
right then and there FaceTime this is
cool you can leave a FaceTime video
message to someone if they don't answer
which is usually the case a lot of times
I miss a lot of calls but it would be
awesome to be able to just go back and
see the message of either someone
getting upset that I didn't answer I
don't know it's going to be really neat
and I'm so excited that they added this
feature in messages they've got new
search filters so you can start a search
and then narrow the terms there's a
catch-up arrow that lets you jump up to
what you missed and replies are so much
better now you can swipe to reply voice
messages are transcribed which I'm so
excited about all of my friends love
doing voice messages and I just feel
like they're tiny voicemails and I don't
I don't like voicemail but now it's
basically turning that tiny voicemail
into text I'm here for it now this new
check-in feature is really cool this
will let your family or friends know
that you've arrived somewhere safely and
automatically and if you haven't got
there yet they can check in and see
where you're at and they'd be able to
see things like battery level cell
service and of course this is all end to
end in encrypted there is a new layout
and design for the iMessages app menu
which I like I feel like they've kind of
put all of those little icons and kind
of hidden them away so you don't have to
see them when you're typing or
accidentally hit them there's also a new
stickers experience so you can create
stickers using live photos and save them
you can add effects and you can also now
react to messages with stickers you'll
be able to use these and access them in
third-party apps or anywhere where
emojis are available airdrop is
something that I cannot live without and
they just announced a new feature called
name drop so basically if I wanted to
give you my contact I just go
oh I just name dropped you I actually
really like that name all you do is you
just bring your phones close together
then the new contact posters will pop up
and you can share contact info
seamlessly this can also be used with
Apple watch and for larger files you can
now leave airdrop range and the content
will still send in full quality over the
Internet that's something that I'm so
excited about because I transfer a ton
of files from my iPad to my computer to
friends to Tyler who's over there we're
always sharing things back and forth so
if we're not in airdrop range anymore
it'll still continue to upload as long
as you have an internet connection oh
man this was also super exciting the new
Mac OS now has a new name and it is Mac
OS Sonoma I'm always looking forward to
seeing what they're going to name it and
of course I can't wait to try it out
there's going to be some new slo-mo
screen savers from all around the world
that will be viewable on Mac OS Sonoma
this WWDC really focused a lot on
widgets and now widgets are on the Mac
and better than ever these widgets can
live right on the desktop and they can
change the look depending upon how your
desktop looks now in the widget Gallery
using continuity it can access iPhone
widgets on the Mac now there was also a
lot of focus about gaming on the Mac
there's a new game mode which will
prioritize the CPU and GPU this allows
for optimized gaming experiences for
smoother frame rates it was also so cool
to see Kojima on the stage bringing us
depth stranding the director's cut to
the Mac I'm also a huge fan of the Apple
watch as you know so it's always so
exciting to see all the new things that
watch OS will have in store for us one
of the biggest watch OS 10 features is
bringing cycling to the Apple watch it
can connect to bluetooth enabled bike
sensors there's new cycling power
workout View and this was super cool
your cycling workouts can mirror on the
iPhone full screen display so if you are
using your phone for navigation and it's
mounted on your bike your Apple watch
will be mirrored to the display as well
they also added some new hiking features
so the compass will Auto generate
Waypoint with GPS there's a new
elevation View and you can see a 3D view
of your saved wave points iPad OS 17
also has some really cool new features
there's new interactive widgets that
will give you quick interactions without
having to actually open the app you can
control everything right from the
widgets there's also now personalized
lock screens just like on the iPhone
with custom wallpapers text fonts colors
and more live activities is also pretty
cool you can keep track of food orders
travel plans sports scores and you can
even keep track of multiple timers it's
about time there's also updates to how
you can work with PDFs in iPad OS
there's autofill custom signatures that
you can use the apple pencil to write
with PDFs in the notes app is pretty
awesome you can also use multiple PDFs
in one app and of course with the apple
pencil this will allow you to annotate
and you can even see the shared PDF
changes that will appear right away in
between devices well thank you guys so
much I had so much fun at WWDC I hope
you guys enjoy the keynote and I can't
wait to get my hands on all of these new
features and devices I'll see you guys
in the next one bye